- We are back and I'm
here with Jordan L. Jones.
Give it up.
(audience cheers)
- Our next guest is a super talented
singer, songwriter and actress.
She does all the things, y'all.
You've seen her as Jordan's co-star
in the Fresh Prince Reboot Bel Air.
But she says her true
passion will always be music.
That's my girl.
She just released her debut EP
with Def Jam records called
"What I Didn't Tell You".
- Yep. And now performing the
holiday classic "Silver Bells"
from the Def the Halls compilation,
give it up for my friend
and co-star, Coco Jones.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(easy going music)
♪ City sidewalks, busy sidewalks ♪
♪ Dressed in holiday style ♪
♪ In the air there's a
feeling of Christmas ♪
♪ Children laughing, people passing ♪
♪ Meeting smile after smile ♪
♪ And on every street corner you hear ♪
♪ Silver bells ♪
♪ It's Christmas time in the city ♪
♪ Ring-a-ling ♪
♪ Hear them ring ♪
♪ Soon it will be Christmas day ♪
♪ Strings of street
lights, even stoplights ♪
♪ Blink a bright red and green ♪
♪ As the shoppers rush
home with their treasures ♪
♪ Hear the snow crunch, kids bunch ♪
♪ This is Santa's big scene ♪
♪ And above all this bustle you hear ♪
♪ Silver bells, silver bells ♪
♪ It's Christmas time in the city ♪
♪ Ring-a-ling ♪
♪ Oh hear them ring ♪
♪ Soon it will be Christmas day ♪
♪ Silver bells ♪
♪ It's Christmas time in the city, yeah ♪
♪ Ring-a-ling ♪
♪ Hear them ring ♪
♪ Soon it will be ♪
♪ Christmas day ♪
Thank you Kelly Clarkson.
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Once again everybody,
let's hear it for Coco Jones!
Pick up her debut EP
"What I Didn't Tell You"
wherever you get your music.
We'll be right back with what I'm liking.